to present the winners for
cinematography we thought it fitting to
select the cameras favorite subject a
beautiful woman here then as a woman who
is not only beautiful but who has won
awards for her distinguished work in
both motion pictures and that other
medium miss Claire Trevor
Clara may I congratulate you on your
recent winning of an award from that
other Academy Thank You Terry you know
it's a very funny thing but I think I
could have won an Emmy last year myself
except with some very very casting
difficulties that they ran into what do
you mean casting well I was up for a
certain part but Nanette Fabray got it
Oh Jerry that's too bad but don't worry
you're going to win someday you know a
man of your rare talent it's bound to
will hustle go can't go without
recognition forever yeah I know but I'm
not entirely without recognition now you
know I've received some glory maybe not
an Oscar or an Emmy but back in 1937 I
won an Elliot and Elliot Watson Elliot
well it's a 4-foot statue of Elliott
Roosevelt carved out of Redwood and was
awarded to the boy with the sharpest
accent our CCC camp
the nominations for black-and-white
cinematography are Boris Kaufman for
babydoll Hal Rossum for the bagsied
brunette guppy for the harder they fall
Josef Lautenberg for somebody up there
likes me and Walter strange for
stagecoach to fury envelope please
the winner is somebody up there likes me
Joseph
the nominations for color cinematography
are Lionel Lyndon for around the world
in 80 days
Harry straddling for the Eddy Duchin
story leon sham Roy for the King and I
loyal Griggs for the 10 commandments and
Jack Cardiff for war and peace the
winner is around the world in 80 days
I'm very very happy for carly linden I'm
working with loyal Griggs and I was well
it's tough to root you know it's a hard
kind of thing